so you're uh you talk about your son
in in comedy he really lives with you
uh well technically well his mom and i
are no longer together so
now he uh he works for me so he's here
at the uh the office all day so
i see him a lot more now than ever
i'm watching him be productive so that's
a good thing that's a very good thing
i saw on your specialty here talking
about
how he he watches videos of other people
playing video games
that's uh what is it called as a twitch
i think
yeah twitch streaming whatever i don't
understand it i always said if i was
gonna have kids
i would rather them smoke pot than play
video games
i just think video games are so
destructive
to uh i may think to life to life man
yeah i think it's like porn in a
relationship but it's funny these days
people make a career out of it so it's
hard to kind of
say that still like yeah if you can make
money
right but you're damn well not making
money watching other [ __ ] do it
that's true but some people i mean a lot
of people you watch people play
basketball or people watch people
play other games like what's the
difference watching someone play pac-man
or something you know that was exactly
the point in the special oh nice
there you go yeah
yeah dude